hier mais on commence d'abord par l'un
des plus beaux paris mariant la fiancée
l'écologie solar impulse a décollé tôt
ce matin de payerne en suisse pour un
vol expérimental de 25 heures
l'avion solaire imaginé par
l'explorateur bertrand piccard doit
voler sans carburant
la grande question c'est de savoir s'il
va pouvoir tenir y compris pendant la
nuit
nicolas chateauneuf sur la piste un
avion aux formes étranges attend le feu
vert pour décoller il est presque sept
heures du matin sur la base militaire de
payerne en suisse dans la salle de
contrôle
la tension est palpable c'est l'heure le
pilote andré borschberg met en route les
quatre moteurs électriques uniquement
alimenté par les 12000 cellules solaires
posés sur les ailes à 35 kilomètres
heure seulement l'avion décolle sous les
yeux des admirateurs
le décollage et les conditions météo
sont idéales qui fonctionne en tout cas
jusqu'à maintenant on croise les doigts
car on avance dans l'inconnu t'as rien
n'est certain that something jusqu'au
bout on sait pas ce qui peut arriver
ap solar impulse est le premier avion a
tenté de voler 25 heures de jour comme
de nuit sans carburant pour charger les
batteries et affronter la nuit il doit
monter à 8500 mètres
le pilote est confiant c'est vraiment un
moment spécial très important toute
l'équipe attend ça depuis le début
depuis presque sept ans si tout se passe
bien cela rime punch devrait entamer un
tour du monde en 2013